how dope is it to see a guy who's like a
peer of yours uh you see Berner making
the Forbes list or the Forbes cover not
even the Forbes list he's on the cover
of that [ __ ] yeah that was big I
mean that [ __ ] is insane because you
know burn has been in the trenches as
like an independent rapper in the bay
forever I don't know a burner for so
long it burner went all tour together
meet him JDS I for me to see how he went
I watched his whole everything I watched
him go from start to now it's crazy it
is truly it's like it's like crazy man I
always say like you know somehow he
doesn't get enough like respect or or
flowers but I'm like this guy's richer
than every rapper everybody like I don't
know I mean maybe like Jay-Z like but
we're like we're talking about like on
some businessman [ __ ] like burner's
richer than everybody I need to make
more money in a day than with [ __ ]
making a month it's crazy like whatever
City you're in
the building is blue and you have to
pull up to get your weed it could be
Detroit it could be wherever you're at
there's a cookies if there's a way it is
recreational oh yeah it's on the Strip
yeah it's crazy everywhere and it's like
a it's like an attraction it's like oh
we gotta we gotta go to the cookie store
oh we come out to LA we gotta go to the
cookie store It's gotta go to the
cookies though and that's not even
mentioning like the clothing line doing
like stupid numbers exactly it's insane
man
yeah yeah he did his thing with that
shout out burner man 100